the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
so today we're going to move on to a
fairly different world than the world
we've been living in and this will be a
world will be living in for quite a few
lectures but before I do that I want to
get back to just finish up something
that Professor Grimson started you may
recall he talked about family trees and
raised the question was it actually
possible to represent all ancestral
relationships as a tree well as a
counterexample I'm sure some of you are
familiar with Oedipus Rex for those of
you who are not I'm happy to give you a
plot summary at the end of the lecture
it's a rather bizarre plot but it was
captured in a wonderful song by Tom lair
the short story is Oedipus ended up
marrying his mother and having four
children and Tom lair if you've never
heard of Tom lair you're missing one of
the world's funniest songwriters and he
had a wonderful song called Oedipus Rex
and I recommend this YouTube as a way to
go and listen to it and you can gather
from the quote what the story is about
I also recommend the play by the way
it's really kind of appalling what goes
on but it's beautiful all right back to
the main topic here's the the relevant
reading a small bit from from later in
the book and then chapter 14 you may
notice that we're not actually going
through the book in order and the reason
we're not doing that is because we're
trying to get you information you need
in time to do problem sets all right so
the topic of today is really uncertainty
and the fact that the world is really
annoyingly hard to understand this is
signpost related to six triple O - but
we won't go into too much detail about
it
we rather things were certain but in
fact they usually are not and this is a
place where six triple o2 diverges from
the typical introductory computer
science course which focuses on things
that are functional given an input you
always get the same output it's
predictable and we like to do that
because that's easier to teach but in
fact for reasons we'll be talking about
it's not nearly as useful if you're
trying to actually write computations
that help you understand the world you
have to face uncertainty head-on analogy
is for many years people believed in
Newtonian mechanics I guess they still
do in 801 maybe that every clock effect
is a cause an Apple falls from the tree
because of gravity and you know where
it's going to land and the world can be
understood causally and people believe
this really for quite a long time most
of history until the early part of the
20th century when the so called
Copenhagen doctrine was put forth the
doctrine they're from Bohr and
Heisenberg two very famous physicists
was one of what they called causal non
determinism and their assertion was that
the world at its very most fundamental
level behaves in a way that you cannot
predict it's okay to make a statement
that X is highly likely to occur almost
certain to occur but for no case can you
make a statement X will occur nothing
has a probability of one this was hard
for us to imagine today when we all know
quantum mechanics but at the turn of the
century this was a shocking statement
and two other very well known physics
physicists Albert Einstein and Schroeder
basically said no this is wrong Bohr
Heisenberg you guys are idiots it's just
not true they probably didn't call them
idiots and this is most exemplified by
Einstein's famous quote that God does
not play dice which is indicative of the
fact that this was actually discussion
that permeated not just the world of
physics but society in general people
really turned it into literally a
religious issue as did Einstein well so
now we should ask the question does it
really matter and to illustrate that I
need two coins I forgot to bring any
coins with me
does anyone got a coin they can lend me
all right now this is where I see how
much the students trust me do I get a
penny do I get a silver dollar all right
so what do we got here all right so this
is someone who's entrusting me with two
quarters not so bad so we'll take these
two quarters and we'll shake them up and
we'll put them down on the table and now
we'll ask a question do we have two
heads to tails or one head and one tail
so who thinks we have two heads who
thinks we have two tails who thinks we
have one of each all right well clearly
everyone except a few people for example
the Indians fanned who clearly believed
in the counterfactual made the most
probabilistic decision but in fact
there's no non determinism here I know
the answer right and so in some sense it
doesn't matter whether it's
deterministic because in fact it's not
causally non-deterministic the answer is
quite clear but you don't know the
answer and so whether or not the world
is inherently unpredictable the fact
that we never have complete knowledge of
the world
suggest that we - well treat it as
inherently unpredictable okay and so
this is called predictive
non-determinism and this really is
what's going to underline pretty much
everything else we're going to be doing
here all right no comments about that
all right I wouldn't do that to you
thank you I know you were wishing to get
interest on the money but you don't get
any yeah all right what was that all
right so when we think about non
determinism in computation we use the
word stochastic process and that's any
process that's ongoing in which the net
state depends upon the previous States
in some random element so typically up
till now when we've written code what
one line of code did depended only on
what the previous lines of code did
there was no randomness here we're going
to have randomness and we can see the
difference if we look at these two
specifications of rolling a die the
first one returns an int between 1 & 6
is what I'll call under determined by
that I mean you can't tell what it's
going to return maybe it will return a
different number each time you call it
but it's not required - maybe it will
return 3 every time you call it the
second specification requires randomness
it says it returns a randomly chosen in
so it requires a stochastic
implementation all right let's look at
how we implement a random process in
Python we start by importing the library
random this is not to say you can report
in any random library you want
is to say you report the library called
random let me get my pen out of here and
we'll use that a lot and then we're
going to use the function in random
called random choice it takes as an
argument a sequence in this case a list
and randomly chooses one member of the
list and it chooses it uniformly it's a
uniform distribution and what that means
is that it's equally probable that it
will choose any number in that list each
time you call it will later look at
distributions that are not uniform not
equally probable where things are
weighted but here it's quite simple it's
just uniform and then we can test it
using Ives test roll take some number of
N and rolls the dive at many times and
creates a string telling us what we got
so let's consider running this on say
test roll of 5 and we'll ask the
question if we run it how probable is it
that it's going to return a string of 5
ones how do we do that
now I know how many people here are
either in 604 1 or have taken 604 1
raise your hand oh good so very few of
you know probability that helps alright
so how do we think about that question
well probability to me at least is all
about counting especially discrete
probability which is what we're looking
at here what you do is you start by
counting the number of events that have
the property of interest
and the number of possible events and
divide one by the other so if we think
about rolling a die five times we can
enumerate all of the possible outcomes
of five rolls so if we look at that what
are the outcomes well I could get five
ones I could get five ones four ones and
a two or four ones under three skip a
few the next one would be three ones two
and A one and A two and A two and
finally at the end all sixes right so
remember we looked before at when we're
looking at optimization problems about
binary numbers and we said we could look
at all the possible choices of items in
the knapsack by vector of zeros and ones
we said how many possible choices are
are there well it dependent how many
binary numbers you could get in that
number of digits well here we're doing
the same thing but instead of base to
its base six and so the number of
possible outcomes of five rolls is quite
high how many of those are five ones
only one of them right so in order to
get the probability of five ones I
divide one by six to the fifth that
makes sense to everybody
so in fact we see it's highly unlikely
probability of five runs is quite small
now suppose we were to ask about the
probability of something else instead of
five one say five three four two one
kind of looks more likely than that than
five ones in a row but of course it
isn't right any specific combination is
equally probable and there are a lot of
them
so this is all the probability we're
going to think about we could think
about this way as simply a matter of
counting the number of possible events
the number of vents that have the
property of interest in this case being
all ones and then simple division given
that framework there are three basic
facts about probability we're going to
be using a lot of so one probabilities
always range from 0 to 1 how do we know
that well we've got a fraction right and
we the denominator is all possible
events the numerator is the subset of
that that's of interest so it has to
range from 0 to the denominator and that
tells us that the fraction has to range
from 0 to 1 so one says it's always
going to happen 0 never so if the
probability of event occurring is P
what's the probability of it not
occurring this follows from the first
bullet it's simply going to be 1 minus P
this is a trick that we'll find we use a
lot because it's often the case when you
want to compute the probability of
something happening it's easier to
compute the probability if it's not
happening and subtract it from 1 and
we'll see an example of that later today
now here's the biggie when events are
independent of each other the
probability of all of the events
occurring is equal to the product of the
probabilities of each of the events
occurring so if the probability of a is
0.5 and the probability of B
is 0.4 the probability of a and B is
what 0.5 times 0.4 you guys can figure
that out
I think it's point 2 so you'd expect
that right that it should be much
smaller than either the first two
probabilities this is the most common
rule it's something we use all the time
in probabilities is so called
multiplicative law we have to be careful
about it however in that it only holds
if the events are actually independent
two events are independent if the
outcome of one has no influence in the
outcome of the other so when we roll the
die we assume that the first roll the
outcome was independent of the of the
second rolls independent of the first
roll independent of the fourth roll when
we looked at the two coins we assume
that heads and tails of the each coin
was independent of the other coin I
didn't for example look at one coin and
make sure that the other one was
different the danger here is that people
often compute probabilities assuming
independence when you don't actually
have independence so let's look at an
example for those of you familiar with
American football the ball New England
Patriots the Denver Broncos or two
prominent teams and let's look at
computing the probability of one of
whether one of them will lose on a given
Sunday so the Patriots have a winning
percentage of seven of eight they've won
seven of their eight games so far and
the Broncos six of eight the probability
of both winning next Sunday we assuming
that this is indicative of how good they
are we can get with the multiplicative
rule so it's 7 over 8 times 6 over 8 or
42 over 60
for we could simplify that fraction I
suppose all right that makes sense
so this is probably a pretty good
estimate of both of them winning next
Sunday so the probability of at least
one of them losing is 1 minus that so
here's an example of why we often use
the 1 minus rule right because we could
compute the probability of both of them
winning by simply multiplying we can we
subtract that from 1 however what about
Sunday December 18th what's the
probability well as it happens that day
the Patriots are playing the Broncos so
now suddenly the outcomes are not
independent the probability of one of
them losing is influenced by the
probability of the other winning right
so you would expect the probability of
one of them losing is much closer to one
then 22 over 64 which is about 1/3 all
right so in this case it's easy but as
we'll see as we get through the term
there are lots of cases where you have
to work pretty hard to understand
whether or not two events really are
independent and if you get it wrong you
get a totally bogus answer right 1/3
versus 1 is a pretty big difference by
the way as it happens the probability of
the Broncos losing is about 1 all right
let's let's go look at some code and
we'll go back to our dice because it's
much easier to simulate dice games than
it is to simulate football games so here
it is and we're going to talk a lot
about simulations so here are rather
than rolling the die I've written a
program to do it
we've already seen the code for rolling
a die and so to run the simulation
typically what we're doing here is I'm
giving you the goal for example are we
going to get five ones the number of
trials each trial in this case will be
say of length five so I'm going to roll
the same die five times say a thousand
different times and then just some text
as to what I'm going to print almost all
the simulations we look at are going to
start with lines that look a lot like
that we're going to initialize some
variable and then we're going to run
some number of trials so in this case
we're going to get from the length of
the goal so if the goal is five ones and
we're going to roll the die five times
if it's ten runs we'll roll the die ten
times so this is essentially one trial
one attempt right and then we'll check
the result and if it has the property we
want in this case it's equal to the goal
then we're going to increment the total
which we initialized up here by one so
we'll keep track which is just the
counting the number of trials that
actually meet the goal then when we're
done what we're going to do is divide
the number that met the goal by the
number of
exactly the counting argument we just
looked at and then we'll print the
result
almost every simulation we look at is
going to have this structure
there'll be an outer loop which is the
number of trials and then inside maybe
we'll have a loop or maybe that won't
will be a single trial will sum up the
results and then we'll divide by the
number of trials all right let's run it
all right so a couple of things are
going to go on here if you look at the
code as we've looked at it before
what you're seeing is I'm computing the
estimated probability by the simulation
and I'm comparing it to the actual
probability which we've already seen how
to compute so if you look at it there
are a couple of things to look at the
estimated probability is pretty close to
the actual probability but not the same
let's go back to the PowerPoint here are
the results and they're at least two
question raised by this result first of
all how did I know that this is what
would get printed remember this is
random how did I know that the estimate
well there's nothing random about the
actual probability but how did I know
that the estimated probability would be
zero and why did it print it twice
because I messed up the PowerPoint any
rate so how do I know what would get
printed well a confession' random dot
choice is not actually random in fact
nothing we can do in a computer is
actually random you can prove that it's
impossible to
build a computer that actually generates
truly random numbers what they do
instead is generate numbers that are
called pseudo-random how do they do that
they have an algorithm that given one
number generates the next number in a
sequence and they start that algorithm
with the seed now typically they get
that seed by reading the clock of the
computer so most computers have a clock
that say keeps track of the number of
microseconds since January 1st 1978 I
don't know if that's still true that's
what UNIX used to do so the notion is
you start your program there's no way of
knowing how many micro seconds have
elapsed and so you're getting a random
number to start the process since you
don't know where it starts you don't
know what the second number is you don't
know what the third number is you don't
know what the fourth number is and so
it's predictably non-deterministic
because you don't know what the seed is
going to be now you can imagine that
this makes programs really hard to debug
every time you run it you something
different could happen now we'll see
often you want them to be unpredictable
but for now we want them to be
predictable makes it easier to prepare
PowerPoint so what you have if we go is
a command you can call random dot seed
and give it a value and say I don't want
you to just choose some random seed I
want you to use zero as the seed for the
same seed you always get the same
sequence of random values and so what
I've done is I set the seed to be I
think 0 in this case not because there's
anything magic about 0
just sort of have it but it made it
predictable as you write programs with
randomness in and when you're debugging
it you will almost surely want to start
by setting random seed to a value so you
get the same answer but make sure your
debug it with more than one value of
this so you didn't just get lucky with
your seed all right so that's how I knew
would how will we get printed the next
question is why did the simulation give
me the wrong answer the actual
probability is three zeros and one two
eight six but it estimated the
probability of zero why is it wrong well
let's think about this I ran a thousand
trials what does it mean to say the
probability is zero it means it tried it
a thousand times and didn't ever get a
sequence of five ones
so the numerator of the division at the
bottom was zero hence the answer is zero
is this surprising well no because if
that's the actual probability of getting
five ones it's not very shocking that in
a thousand trials I'd never happened
right you know it's not a surprising
result and so we have to be careful when
we run these things to understand the
difference between what's in this case
an actual probability and what
statisticians call a sample probability
so what we got with the sample was zero
so what's the obvious thing to do if
you're doing a simulation of an event
and the event is pretty rare you want to
try it
on a very large number of trials so
let's go back to our code and we'll
change it to instead of a thousand a
million you can see up here by the way
where I set their seed now let's run it
we did a lot better if we look at here
our estimated probability it's three
zeros one to eight still not quite the
actual probability but darn close and
maybe if I done ten million it would
have been even closer so if you're
writing a simulation to compute the
probability of an event and the event is
moderately rare then you better run a
lot of trials before you believe your
estimated probability in a week or so
we'll actually look at that more
mathematically and say what is a lot how
do we know what is enough
all right what are the morals here moral
one I've just told you takes a lot of
trials to get a good estimate of the
frequency of a rare event moral two we
should always if we're getting an
estimated probability no that and
probably say that and not confuse it
with the actual probability the third
moral here is it was kind of stupid to
do a simulation since there was a very
simple closed for an answer that we
could compute that would really tell us
what the actual probability is why even
bother with the simulation well we're
going to see why now because simulations
can be very useful let's look at another
problem this is the famous birthday
problem some of you have seen it what's
the probability of at least two people
in a group having the same birthday
there's a URL at the bottom that's
pointing to a Google Form I'd like
please all of you have a computing
device to go to it and fill out your
birthday it's anonymous so we won't know
how old you are don't worry actually
it's only the date it's not the year all
right so suppose there were 367 people
in the group roughly the number of
people who took the six triple zero one
six hundred midterm all right if there
are 367 people what's the probability of
at least two of them sharing a birthday
one by something called the pigeonhole
principle right you got some number of
holes and if you have more pigeons than
holes two pigeons have to share a hole
what about smaller numbers well if we
make a simplifying assumption that each
birthdate is equally likely then there's
actually a nice closed form solution for
it again this is a question where it's
easier to compute the opposite of what
you're trying
you do and subtract it from one and so
this fraction is giving the probability
of two people not sharing a birthday the
proof that this is right it's a little
bit elaborate but you can trust me it's
accurate but it's a formula and it's not
that complicated a formula though
numbers like three hundred six and six
factorial are big all right so let's
approximate a solution we'll write a
simulation and see if we get the same
answer that that formula gave us so
here's the code for that two arguments
the number of people in the group and
the number that we asking do they have
the same birthday
so since I'm assuming for now that every
birthday is equally likely the possible
dates range from 1 to 366 because some
years have a February 29th
I'll keep track of the number of people
born in each date by starting with none
and then for P and the range of number
of people I'll make a random choice of
the possible dates and increment that
element of the list by one and then at
the end we can say look at the maximum
number of birthdays and see if it's
greater than or equal to the number of
same so that tells us that and then we
can actually look at the birthday
problem number of people the number of
same n as usual the number of trials so
number of hits of zero for T and range
number of trials if same date is true
then we'll increment the number of hints
by one and then as usual divided by the
number of trials and we'll try it for
people in for ten twenty forty and a
hundred people
then just will print the estimated
probability and the actual probability
computed using that formula I showed you
I've not shown you but I've imported a
library called math because it is a
factorial implementation that's way
faster than the recursive one that we've
seen before all right let's run it
and we'll see we get so for 10 the
estimated probability is 0.1 1 now so as
you can see the estimates are really
pretty good once again we have this
business that for 100 we're estimating 1
when the real answer is point many many
many nines but again this is sample
probability just means in the number of
trials we did every one for a hundred
people there was a shared birthday this
is a number that usually surprises
people as to why with a hundred people
the probability is so high but we could
work out the formula and see it and as
you can see the estimates are pretty
good from my simulation all right now
now we're going to see why we did a
simulation in the first place
suppose we want the probability of three
people sharing a birthday instead of two
it's pretty easy to see how we change
the simulation right I even made it a
parameter I just changed the number two
to number three the math on the other
hand is ugly why is the math so much
uglier for three than for two because
for two the complementary problem the
number we're subtracting from one is
simply the question of our all birthdays
different so do two people share our
birthday is one minus or off does
everybody of a different birthday on the
other hand for three people the
complementary problem is a complicated
disjunct a bunch of ORS either all
birthdays are distinct or two people
share a birthday and the rest are
distinct or there are two groups of two
people sharing a birthday and everything
is distinct so you can see here this a
lot of possibilities
and so it's one - now a very complicated
formula and in fact if you try and look
how to do this most people will tell you
don't bother here's a kind of a good
approximation but the math gets very
hairy in contrasts changing the
simulation is dead easy we can do that
whoops so if we come over here for the
code all I have to do is change this to
to a three
and I'm going to leave in this code
which is the wrong code the computing
the actual probability now for two
people sharing rather than three because
I want to make it easy for you to see
the difference between what happens when
we look at three shared rather than two
shared
and I get invalid syntax that's not good
that's what happens when I type in
real-time
why do I have invalid syntax pardon one
person at Ana oh that's not a good line
so now we see that if we get say 2n
equals 104 to you'll remember it was
0.99 but for three it's only 0.6 three
so we see going from two sharing or
three sharing gets us a radically
different answer not surprisingly but we
also in the real thing I wanted you to
see is how easy it was to answer this
question to simulation and that's a
primary reason we use simulations to get
probabilistic questions rather than
sitting down and the pencil on paper and
doing fancy probability calculations
because there's often way easier to do a
simulation we can see that in spades if
we look at the next question
let's think about this assumption that
all birthdays are equally likely well as
you can see this is a chart of how
common birth dates are in the u.s. a
heatmap
and you'll see for example that February
29th is a quite an uncommon birthday so
we should probably treat that
differently somewhat surprisingly you'll
see that July 4th is a very uncommon
birthday as well it's easy to understand
why February 29th the only thing I can
figure out for July 4th is obstetricians
don't like working on holidays and so
they induce labor sometime around the
second or so to the third so they don't
have to come to work on the 4th of the
fifth sounds a horrible thought but I
can't think of any other explanation for
this anomaly
you'll probably if you look at it see
Christmas Day is not so common either so
now the question which we can answer
since you've all fill out this form is
how exceptional or MIT students we like
to think that you're different in every
respect so are your birthday's
distributed differently than other dates
have we got that data all right so now
we'll go look at that
we should have a heat map for you guys I
this one yes all right so here it is and
we can see that well they don't seem to
be banded quite as much in the summer
months probably says more about your
parents and does about you but you can
see that indeed we do have wow we have a
day where there are five birthdays that
look like oh no oh wow you want to raise
your hand if you're born in February
12th uh-huh all right so you are
exceptional that you lie about when
you're born but if you hadn't lied I
think we would have still seen the
probabilities would hold how many people
were there do we know
146 people 112 unique birthdays so
indeed the probability does work okay
so we know you're exceptional in a funny
way well you can imagine how hard it
would be to adjust the analytic model to
account for a weird distribution of
birth dates but again adjusting the
simulation model is easy I could have
gone back to that heat map I showed you
or birthdays in the US and gotten a
separate probability for each day but I
was too lazy and instead what I observed
was that we had this a few days like
February 29th highly unlikely and this
band in the middle of people who were
conceived in the late fall and early
winter so what I did is I duplicated
some dates so the 58th day of the year
February 29th occurs only once the dates
before that I said let's may pretend
they occur four times what only matters
here is not how often they occur but the
relative frequency and then the updates
after that occur four times except for
the dates in that band which has going
to have occur yet more often so now and
don't worry about the exact details here
but what I'm doing is simply adjusting
the simulation to change the probability
of each date getting chosen by same date
and then I can run the simulation model
and again with a very small change to
code I've modeled something that's
mathematically enormous ly complex I
have no idea to actually do this
probability mathematically but the code
is as you can see quite straightforward
so let's go to that here so what I'm
going to do is comment this one out and
uncomment this more complicated set of
dates
and see what we get
and again it changes quite dramatically
you might remember before was around I
think points six something for a hundred
and now it's 0.75 so getting away from
the notion that birthdays are uniformly
distributed to saying some birthdays are
more common than others
again dramatically changes the answer
and we can easily look at that so that
gets us to the big topic of simulation
models it's a program that describes a
computation that provides information
about the possible behaviors of a system
I say possible behaviors because I'm
particularly interested in stochastic
systems they're descriptive not
prescriptive in the sense that they
describe the possible outcomes they
don't tell you how to achieve a possible
outcomes this is different from what
we've looked at earlier in the course
where we looked at optimization models
so an optimization model is prescriptive
it tells you how to achieve an effect
how to get the most value out of your
knapsack how to find the shortest path
from A to B in a graph in contrast a
simulation model says if I do this
here's what happens it doesn't tell you
how to make something happen so it's
very different and it's why we need both
while we need optimization models and we
need simulation models we have to
remember that a simulation model is only
an approximation to reality you know I
put in an approximation to the
distribution of birth dates but it
wasn't quite right and as a very famous
statistician George box said all models
are wrong
but some are actually very useful in the
next lecture we'll look at a useful
class of models
when do we use simulations typically as
we've just shown to model systems that
are mathematically intractable like the
birthday problem we just looked at in
other situations to extract intermediate
results something that happens along the
way to the answer and as I hope you've
seen that simulations are used because
we can play what if games by
successively refining it we started with
a simple simulation that assumed that we
only asked the question of did two
people share a birthday we showed how we
could change it to ask to three people
share a birthday we then saw that we
could change it to assume a different
distribution of birth dates in in the
group and so we can start with something
simple and we get it ever more complexed
to answer questions what if we're going
to start in the next lecture by
producing a samuel simulation of random
of a random walk and with that I'll stop
and see you guys soon
you